bonjour et bienvenue dans cette nouvelle
édition d'en quête d'europe dans cette
émission je vous emmène en allemagne un
pays qui voit sa population décliner et
qui cherche à attirer les cerveaux
notamment des pays en crise direction
ensuite la grande-bretagne où le
gouvernement conservateur de david
cameron fait la chasse aux étrangers
clandestins non sans susciter la
polémique
enfin terminus au portugal un pays en
crise qui cherche à attirer les riches
retraités européens en les exonérant
d'impôt
à l'heure des plans de rigueur
l'annoncent fait grincer mais d'abord
direction lampedusa avec jérôme rabier
une petite île italienne qui voit tous
les jours des corps de passagers
clandestins s'échouer sur ses plages
donc jérôme lampedusa reste la porte
d'entrée de l'immigration clandestine en
europe
effectivement n'aura puisque l'an
dernier c'est presque vingt-cinq mille
migrants qui ont transité par cette
petite île italienne
donc le problème il n'est pas nouveau
c'est juste qu'on parle de lampedusa à
chaque nouvelle tragédie de
l'immigration comme celle du 3 octobre
dernier où trois cent soixante six
personnes ont perdu la vie à quelques
centaines de mètres des côtes italiennes
alors les associations dénoncent un
cimetière géant en méditerranée puisque
lors des 20 dernières années c'est
presque vingt mille migrants qui ont
perdu la vie dans cette mer méditerranée
donc on vous suit à lampedusa
planté face à la mer 366 arbres pour ne
jamais oublier ce qui est arrivé à 600
mètres des côtes de lampedusa le 3
octobre dernier un drame de
l'immigration comme cette île la peine
20 kilomètres carrés plus proche de la
tunisie que de la sicile ans vit depuis
20 ans ici l'arrivée où la mort de
migrants fait partie du quotidien
vito fiorino était en mer cette nuit là
quand avec des amis il a été réveillé
par des cris ou mal les personnes on
apercevait une marée humaine à perte de
vue
j'ai encore des frissons quand je
repense à cette image
ces personnes hurlait elle agitait les
bras en l'air on en a remonté de brousse
possible sur un peu et quand on est
rentré au port qu'on les a sortis sur le
quai on nous a dit qu'on avait sauvé 40
se décider à réagir l'europe dépêche sur
place le président de la commission
européenne josé manuel barosso avant le
sommet européen du 25 octobre qui doit
aborder la politique migratoire de lieux
on
mais à part mettre à juin prochain les
discussions après les élections
européennes
rien n'est décidé rien n'a donc changé
pour lampedusa et ses 6000 habitants qui
continuent de vivre au milieu des
vestiges de ces traversées périlleuses
nous sommes ici au cimetière de bateaux
situés en plein centre ville
c'est là que les bateaux d'émigrants
sont mis après leur arrivée au port ils
sont je dis ici nous sommes en plein
centre-ville juste à côté du stade de
foot à 100 mètres de la mairie
c'est ça la réalité de lampedusa c'est
ce que les habitants vivent tous les
jours
les images parlent d'elles même nom
c'est un spectacle désolant
on voit souvent des migrants venir
fouiller la à la recherche d'objets
perdus mais il n'y a rien à sauver ici
même pas le bois des bateaux le
sentiment d'abandon et vivace nous ne
nous sentons pas italien voilà la
réponse des lampes et du sien qu'il
affiche sur les murs de la ville
dépourvue d'hôpital ou encore de tout à
l'égout lille et sous-équipées l'europe
est elle aussi accusée de ne rien faire
pour ce territoire qu'il ne vit que de
la pêche et du tourisme
seule avancée depuis la catastrophe
l'italie a décidé de renforcer sa
surveillance en méditerranée
les bateaux d'émigrants sont désormais
systématiquement secourus même loin des
côtes italiennes
ce sont les garde-côtes de lampedusa qui
en sont chargés sept navires dont 4
d'intervention rapide et 75 hommes sous
ses ordres
voilà ce dont dispose le commandant
canaris les pour mener à bien cette
mission navale construite avec des fonds
européens et notre programme fait aussi
partie d'un projet européen
ferradj et ap à l'heure où je vous parle
nous avons effectué plusieurs centaines
d'opérations de secours et rien que pour
cette année et nous avons sauvé plus de
13000 personnes par terre une fois sauvé
direction le centre de rétention de
l'île
prévu pour accueillir 250 personnes
alors qu'ils sont parfois plus de 1000
combien de temps resteront de cilicie la
loi prévoit 72 heures mais en réalité
cela dépend de la situation dans les
autres centres en italie
s'il ne restait pas des semaines comme
c'est parfois le cas
lampedusa pourrait faire face sans
conséquences sur l'économie locale sur
la vie de la population
on pourrait même être fiers de sauver
ces vies humaines un espoir partagé par
la maire de la ville qui a été plaidé à
bruxelles pour un véritable changement
de politique européenne en matière
d'immigration
car selon les règles actuelles le pays
d'arrivée doit gérer seules les demandes
de droit d'asile des immigrés l'italie
comme d'autres pays du sud réclament une
solidarité plus importante
photo ddm pas dans le futur de lampedusa
peu changé s'ils changent les politiques
d'asile et si on change les politiques
d'accueil
s'il en p2a et respecté dans sa mission
de sauver des gens et n'est plus
seulement considérée comme une prison au
milieu de la méditerranée
s est belle sont limpides aux invasions
mével sur tout et si l'on paie 12 à sort
enfin de sa marginalité
on aura alors la possibilité de créer
une vraie politique de cohésion sociale
et d'intégration pour améliorer la vie
des habitants
un rêve entre les mains des dirigeants
européens
pas pressé de parler d'immigration avant
les élections européennes de mai
prochain
les drames en méditerranée risquent
pourtant encore de tourmenter leur
conscience si rien n'est fait jérôme
qu'est ce qui a changé depuis ce
naufrage alors les autorités italiennes
ont mis en place un plan d'urgence
l'opération marenostrum le coût de ce
dispositif c'est soixante mille euros
par jour donc il y a bien eu des moyens
supplémentaires dégagés pour porter
assistance aux bateaux en difficulté
mais il ya aussi le problème de la
politique des visas et notamment du
droit d'asile
effectivement pour l'instant il faut
avoir posé le pied en europe pour
demander le droit d'asile
donc ils doivent traverser pour faire
ces demandes la mère de l'île de
lampedusa djouzi nicolini qu'on a vu
dans le reportage
elle est prône un changement radical que
les demandes d'asile puisse être déposée
dans les ambassades des pays européens
en afrique dans les pays d'origine parce
qu'actuellement ces immigrés ils
viennent principalement de syrie de
libye d'erythrée de somalie dépit pas
vraiment démocratique et aurait droit à
ce droit d'asile et comme d'habitude le
rôle de l' agence frontex l'agencé qui
supervise la surveillance des frontières
extérieures de l'europe a été critiqué
et les états européens ont décidé
d'aller plus loin lors d'un sommet qui
s'est tenu quelques semaines après la
catastrophe avec la création de
ressources pour la surveillance des
frontières de l'europe en complément de
frontex
alors tout simplement il va y avoir une
coopération entre états alors que
jusqu'à maintenant chaque état a la
responsabilité de sa zone maritime
mais ce programme il est d'ores et déjà
critiquée et les détracteurs ainsi sur
le fait mal que le budget de ces agences
et il a été diminué lors du dernier vote
du budget de l'union européenne
placée sous le signe de l'austérité
merci jérôme merci moi l'allemagne c'est
un peu le nouvel eldorado des
travailleurs immigrés pour faire face à
son déficit chronique de main d'oeuvre
les entreprises font appel à des
cerveaux étrangers notamment dans les
pays en crise au sud de l'europe
paul bouffard s'est rendu en bavière
hall dans quel but l'allemagne va-t-elle
chercher ses cerveaux étrangers
alors c'est un phénomène qui prend de
l'ampleur aujourd'hui celui de ces
jeunes diplômés grecs italiens espagnols
qui quittent leur pays natal pour
rejoindre l'eldorado allemand de
l'emploi
l'allemagne est vieillissante elle est
en plein déclin démographique
une femme allemande sur cinq ne ferait
pas d'enfant le pays manque de jeunes
qualifiés et il va tout simplement les
piquer au pays d'europe du sud donc là
on vous suit à nuremberg où vous vous
êtes rendu avec mélanie bon temps
8h52 c'est un employé comme les autres
qui passent les tourniquets depuis 2011
christos travail ici près de nuremberg
gh chez siemens energy
mais l'ingénieur de 35 ans vient de loin
il a fui la grèce et sa crise du jour au
lendemain
son salaire a été divisé par deux je
n'ai pas mis beaucoup de temps à trouver
du travail en allemagne grâce un
chasseur de têtes
thessalonique en grèce j'ai reçu une
invitation de la semaine c'est j'ai eu
un entretien dans bourges et un mois
plus tard
christos est en poste expert en énergie
sismique une immigration facilité il
trouve son logement en ligne et les
formalités administratives réglées par
l'employeur
ma fiancée médecin elle travaille
actuellement en grèce et nous avons vu
d'ailleurs qu'elles viennent ici en
allemagne et qu'elle cherche elle aussi
à un travail lorsque nous nous voulons
fonder une famille notre famille ici
l'entreprise crée même un pôle
d'ingénieurs étrangers
après avoir sonné l'austérité les
allemands accueille les cerveaux hélène
dans le service huit employés sur disque
sont originaires de grèce c'est devenu
difficile de trouver des experts
allemands dans ce train il n'y a pas de
spécialisation sismique en allemagne on
doit aller plus au sud de l'europe
pourront trouver en grèce en italie ou
en turquie soumet la grèce grèce de la
meilleure option
on est aujourd'hui 42 % des allemands
ont plus de 50 ans si rien n'est fait le
pays manque rade six millions de
travailleurs d'ici dix ans alors
ingénieur expert mais aussi personnels
de santé deviennent une cible
prioritaire pour les chasseurs de tête à
l'agencé allemande pour l'emploi
on développe même une campagne
européenne de recrutement the job of my
life présente sur toutes les bourses à
l'emploi d'europe du sud
objectif draguer les travailleurs
étrangers ici en allemagne où le chômage
est relativement limité le taux de
chômage en août était de 6,3 pour cent
ce qui est très faible comparé à
l'europe
dans un pays comme la grèce il est de 27
% ce qui est évidemment très élevés et
c'est pourquoi nous ne pouvons
qu'encourager les travailleurs grecs à
venir chez nous à venir à nous quand ils
ont bien sûr délégation je pense que
quand la croissance reviendra en grèce
et bien ces travailleurs reviendront
dans leur pays avec bien entendu leurs
compétences et en plus ils parleront
depuis 12 mois pas moins de vingt-cinq
mille nouveaux travailleurs grecs sont
arrivés en allemagne alors comme un
nuremberg les communautés s'organise
dionysos tous les grecs disent ils le
connaissent c'est un peu l'ange gardien
de ses compatriotes
avec son association il fait la
passerelle entre grèce et allemagne aide
administrative mais pas seulement des
cours d'allemand aussi maîtriser la
langue de goethe reste un sésame
indispensable pour décrocher ces emplois
ça a commencé il ya deux ans pour nous
aussi c'était quelque chose de nouveau
et beaucoup de grecs sont venues d'un
coup des familles des jeunes des enfants
et il faisait la queue devant notre but
origines des uns étant nous avons des
ingénieurs mathématiciens des
professeurs et bien sûr aussi des
médecins
beaucoup de médecins et c'est le cas de
vasiliadis docteur en biologie
moléculaire et génétique blessé par la
caricature des grecs paresseux diffusé
en allemagne
il a quand même fait le voyage car en
grèce il n'avait qu'un petit boulot de
chauffeur de taxi il a bien failli se
retrouver à dormir dans la rue comme il
le dit son pays ne pouvait plus le faire
vivre
je peux comprendre la plupart des
européens leur vision de la situation en
grèce
mais il y en a un que je ne comprends
pas c'est ch le veulent le ministre des
finances allemand il a dit que c'était
de la faute des grecs
il peut bien sûr accusé le gouvernement
qui a mal diriger le pays mais il ne
doit pas accuser le peuple si on
m'appelait et qu'on disait tu as une
offre d'emploi en grèce
je serai dans le premier avion pour y
retourner
pour l'instant vasiliadis continue son
aventure dans l'eldorado allemand son
équivalence de diplôme tamponnais en
main l'homme est en attente d'un poste à
l'hôpital de nuremberg
paul on voit bien dans votre reportage
que de nombreux grecs ont fait le choix
de s'exiler pour quelles raisons en
grèce le taux de chômage des moins de 25
ans frôlent avec les 60 % en allemagne
c'est seulement 8 % donc il n'y a pas
photo l'allemagne a besoin de
travailleurs rien que l'an passé c'est
33000 actifs supplémentaires qui sont
venus du sud il n'y a pas une position
petit peu cynique de la part de
l'allemagne que d'aller chercher ces
cerveaux dans les pays en crise alors
qu'elle même a eu une attitude pas très
solidaire durant la crise totalement y
ait un petit nice mme dans tout ça vous
vous rappelez peut-être de cette une du
journal allemand bild qui titrait ces
grecs paresseux ils n'ont qu'à vendre
leur gilet même l'acropole pour sortir
de la crise alors on est bien loin de ce
temps aujourd'hui le pôle emploi
allemand a lancé une campagne à
destination des pays du sud
ils sont présents dans toutes les foires
à l'emploi de grèce mais je peux vous
dire aussi que certains länder allemands
ont signé des programmes des changes
avec l'espagne et le portugal
et puis il ya quelque chose un peu
intéressant c'est qu'il ya même un vrp
de luxe la chancellière angela merkel
elle-même lors d'un déplacement récent
en espagne a invité ces jeunes espagnols
à venir travailler chez elle merci paul
rentrez chez vous et et 2013 à londres
des campagnes publicitaires affichent
ces mots à destination des immigrés
clandestins les invitant à rentrer chez
eux sous peine d'être arrêté
des campagnes publicitaires qui ont
largement alimenté le débat sur
l'immigration qui fait rage actuellement
en grande bretagne flora sauvage à
traverser la manche
direction l'angleterre flora on a eu le
cas du plombier polonais et quelques
années après nous voilà avec la grande
bretagne qui refusent l'entrée des
bulgares et des roumains
oui en fait au 1er janvier 2014 les
restrictions au droit du travail ont été
levées pour les roumains et les bulgares
si bien que pendant plusieurs mois à
l'automne 2013
autre manche il ya eu des rumeurs
insinuant que des hordes d'étrangers
elle est débarquée dans ce contexte l
été 2013 des camionnettes ont sillonné
certains quartiers de londres
camionnette avec d'une grande campagne
de publicité à l'encontre des immigrés
sans papiers leur disant go home en fait
ce est en gros rentrez chez vous sinon
vous allez être arrêté et il y a eu
également une campagne de sms envoyés
donc on vous suit dans la banlieue de
londres juillet 2013
une campagne anti immigrés s'étale dans
les rues de londres et fait les gros
titres des journaux télévisés un
durcissement de la politique
d'immigration qui inquiète plusieurs
secteurs d'activité en manque de main
d'oeuvre comme l'agriculture
alastair brooks emploi depuis des années
des étrangers pour cueillir ses fraises
et framboises
mais au 1er janvier 2014 le programme de
travailleurs agricoles saisonniers qui
lui permet d'embaucher pendant six mois
des roumains des bulgares va arriver à
son terme le but
privilégiez les travailleurs
britanniques sur les 200 travailleurs
saisonniers qui sont ici environ 180
sont étrangers
petru à 32 ans dès que la saison est
terminée il repart en roumanie
c'est ma dixième année oui c'est ça
c'est ma dixième année c'était une très
bonne opportunité quand j'étais étudiant
et puis ensuite j'ai eu mon diplôme j'ai
fini l'université que finalement j'ai
continué parce que ça me plaît les
agriculteurs comme alasdair peine à
recruter des britanniques pour
travailler aux champs pour ramasser ses
fruits il emploie donc des roumains des
bulgares des polonais mais aussi des
espagnols
on n'arrive pas à trouver à ces gens
dans le kent qu'ils soient prêts à
travailler dans les champs
car c'est un travail temporaire on est
donc obligé d'embaucher des gens qui
viennent de l'étranger
bonjour peter voici peter et roxana qui
dirige une équipe en venant travailler
en grande bretagne
roxana peut doubler son salaire et vivre
correctement roumanie ici on gagne plus
d'argent
en roumanie on gagne 200 livres en un
mois seulement tout le monde ici vient
pour l'argent alasdair brooks appréhende
les effets de la fin du programme qui
lui permettait d'embauché roumains et
bulgares
car sans cueilleurs ses fraises et
framboises ne pourront pas être récoltés
en fait ce qui va se passer c'est que la
production horticole va être exporté à
l'étranger on voit déjà des producteurs
de salades au royaume uni avec des
business en hongrie en pologne
ils sont basés ici mais leur production
est en europe de l'est
et ça va pas s'arrêter après ça sera la
russie la chine mais ça va aussi être
ailleurs
les conséquences du repli sur soi
pourrait être dramatique pour
l'industrie comme le redoute l'union
nationale des agriculteurs
le comble c'est que jusqu'ici nous
autorisions 21 mille travailleurs
saisonniers à venir ici et ensuite 99%
d'entre eux repartent chez eux mais
dorénavant en mettant un terme à ce
programme de travailleurs agricoles
ils pourront venir et travailler de
manière permanente
donc cette mesure va en fait augmenter
potentiellement le nombre d'immigrés au
royaume uni sous la pression du parti
ukip
le gouvernement cherche par tous les
moyens à réduire le nombre d'immigrés ce
soir là un débat réuni nigel farrage le
leader du parti eurosceptique et
d'autres orateurs au centre des
discussions la question de l'immigration
juste une question
trois cent mille emplois ont été créés
l'année dernière un tiers de ces emplois
est allé au britannique et les deux
tiers à des travailleurs nés à
l'étranger
vous trouvez ça normal populiste
nigel farrage agite le spectre de
l'invasion d'étrangers qu'il mettrait à
mal la cohésion de la société anglaise
avec tony blair au pouvoir 4 millions
d'immigrés sont venus royaume uni un
chiffre considérable qui a conduit à des
changements radicaux et maintenant la
majorité du pays dit attendez j'ai
jamais voulu on doit avoir une politique
d'immigration dont le principe est de
faire venir des gens sans casier
judiciaire sans maladie et avec tes
compétences
en 2004 déjà la grande bretagne avait
ouvert ses portes à la pologne qui
venait d'entrer dans l'union
neuf ans après un demi million
d'immigrés comme ukash se sont installés
outre manche et le polonais est devenue
la deuxième langue parlée en angleterre
pour le représentant des polonais de
grande bretagne que discours
anti-immigrés ambiant est l'éternel
débat qui agite le royaume uni en 2004
la grande bretagne avait besoin de sang
frais parce que l'économie était en
pleine expansion
mais maintenant le contexte est très
différent aujourd'hui
après neuf ans la situation économique
n'est pas très bonne et les gens ont un
peu peur tiraillé par les bons scores du
you keep davis cameron veut se montrer
inflexible sur la question de
l'immigration
mais ses marges de manoeuvre sont
limitées car les règles de libre
circulation en europe s'applique à tous
y compris à la grande bretagne
flora on voit clairement dans votre
reportage que la grande bretagne a
d'énormes besoins de main d'oeuvre alors
finalement quel est le but de david
cameron alors son but c'est de faire
passer sous la barre des cent mille le
nombre d'arrivées net d'immigrés en 2015
il veut durcir les conditions d'accès
notamment prestations sociales
il ya bien dit que le système de santé
n'était pas un système de santé
internationales mais c'est un système de
santé britannique qui doit être réservé
en premier lieu aux britanniques
c'est tout un ensemble de mesures qui
visent à décourager finalement les
immigrés à venir en grande-bretagne et
flora comment ses actions elle était
perçue dans les pays étrangers c'est sûr
que ces campagnes anti immigrés ont été
plutôt mal perçu aussi bien en france
qu'en roumanie en bulgarie les immigrés
que j'ai rencontrés dans les champs dans
le kent était assez choqué par les
propos qu'ils étaient tenus à leur
encontre
d'autant que eux ne souhaitait pas
s'installer sur le sol britannique
il souhaitait juste travailler pendant
six mois et puis repartir dans leur pays
puis faut quand même dire que malgré
toutes les prédictions qui avait été
donné il n'y a pas eu d'afflux massif
d'immigrés en grande bretagne depuis le
1er janvier 2014
merci flora s'il y a un pays qui est
ravi de cette libre circulation c'est
bien le portugal pour faire face à la
crise et attirer les investisseurs
étrangers tous les moyens sont bons y
compris offrir une exonération d'impôts
aux riches retraités européens
c'est mounir soucis qui nous en parle
mounir comment expliquer l'engouement
des retraités européens pour le portugal
alors dans les années 2000 la
destination privilégiée pour les
retraités européens c'était le maroc le
maroc avec son niveau de vie très très
bon marché qui donnait des conditions de
vie très confortable pour les retraités
qui s'est installé là bas
mais depuis les printemps arabes eh bien
les retraités réfléchissent à deux fois
avant de s'implanter d'investir dans un
pays où il pourrait potentiellement y
avoir des troubles politiques
même si aujourd'hui le maroc reste
stable mais mounir j'imagine que ce
n'est pas que le soleil portugais qui
attire ces retraités bien non le
gouvernement fait une offre très
séduisante pour attirer les retraités
une incitation fiscale pour les invités
à poser leurs valises au portugal
alors vous imaginez que ce cadeau fiscal
passe assez mal notamment chez les
retraités qui le voient leur pension de
retraite fondre à chaque cure
d'austérité
et donc on vous suit à lisbonne
habitué à voir sa population s'exiler le
portugal serait-il sur le point de
devenir une terre d'accueil
si le pays a la cote auprès des
touristes de nombreux européens songent
taille posé leurs valises notamment les
retraités
cédric et français est agent immobilier
à lisbonne depuis plusieurs années il
conseille les candidats à l'installation
je viens de recevoir un mail du frère de
celui qui habite au luxembourg lui
l'élite en france et il a traité les
mêmes informations pour pouvoir face à
l'essai depuis quelques mois ses clients
changent et le portugal devient la
destination pour passer ses vieux jours
on a noté une augmentation mais
exponentielle du nombre de retraités qui
souhaitent s'installer au portugal qui
font des demandes au moins pour
s'installer à lisbonne ses traits
marqués c'est vraiment très net c on a
aujourd'hui pratiquement une demande par
jour à deux demandes par jour ce qui
n'était pas le cas encore ya six mois
car depuis le début de l'année 2013 le
gouvernement propose une mesure fiscale
très attirante pour les seniors
étrangers une exonération d'impôts
pendant 10 ans pour les anciens salariés
du privé seule condition résidait la
moitié de l'année sur le territoire
jacques un ancien parisien s'est
installé à lisbonne il ya six mois
de toute façon j'avais choisi de venir
m'installer au portugal et pour pour la
ville pour le climat pour la la
gentillesse et dix ans le côté
extrêmement
extrêmement accueillants de nos amis
portugais à la clé un cadre de vie
agréable et une réduction substantielle
de ses impôts je cherchais un moyen de
pouvoir minorer la charge fiscale qui
m'est imposé actuellement le portugal
accueille à bras ouverts ce type
d'exilés le pays en quête d'argent frais
compte sur eux pour sortir de la crise
dans ce cabinet d'avocats fiscalistes on
légitime cette politique ils vos
intérêts des personnes d'autres pays
pour vivre et pour il peut et plus pour
en même temps pour solutionner des
problèmes économiques aussi et des
recettes fiscales
c'est vrai qu'ils vont être ici en train
de vivre et ils vont payer le terreau et
à tous les jours tous les impôts en ce
qui concerne leur patrimoine et ça sera
ce sera une façon aussi d'augmenter les
recettes des revenus fiscale du
gouvernement
depuis trois ans le gouvernement
portugais fait face à une grogne sociale
sans précédent des coupes budgétaires
successives ont fait descendre des
milliers de personnes dans la rue dans
les cortèges
de plus en plus de temps grise comme
cette ancienne bibliothécaire qui a
perdu 400 euros de pension en deux ans
alors les cadeaux fiscaux accordés aux
étrangers sont dures à avaler
depuis un an elle milite dans une
association de défense des retraités
aujourd'hui ils sont plus de 5000 que
n'ont pas les européens ne sont pas nos
ennemis nous devons nous unir
mais il faut que les gens comprennent
qu'ils ne peuvent pas choisir l'endroit
où ils vivent juste en fonction des
avantages fiscaux qu'ils offrent des
conditions de vie de plus en plus
difficile pour la population portugaise
dans ce centre de santé de la banlieue
de lisbonne
les journées sont rythmées par les
flashs d'information à la une encore et
toujours la crise économique
au moment où je vous parle la réunion
entre les ministres portugais et les
commissaires européens vient de se
terminer
la journée va se poursuivre par un
déjeuner de travail ici ses
pensionnaires ont vécu l'essor
économique du portugal depuis son entrée
dans l'union européenne
aujourd'hui marche arrière comme tous
ils subissent de plein fouet les
réductions budgétaires g 87 ans et avec
ce nouveau gouvernement
aujourd'hui j'ai perdu la gratuité de
certains soins
je ne suis plus indemnisés pour isabelle
à la tête du centre les plans
d'austérité successifs pèse sur les
budgets et sur la qualité d'accueil
besoin de manette super fou tout ce
qu'on a pu mais nous n'avons pas assez
d'argent pour acheter la nourriture les
médicaments et on sent bien que l'on
doit réduire tous les services que l'on
propose on peut plus en faire autant
c'est très dur pour les gens de vivre
avec des retraites qui n'arrêtent pas de
baisser 4 et les coupes vont se
poursuivre le prochain budget table sur
4 milliards d'économies et les retraités
vont de nouveau en pâtir le gouvernement
a déjà prévu de baisser de 10% les
pensions des fonctionnaires
mounir on voit bien que ce phénomène
inquiète les retraités portugais calé
son ampleur alors aujourd'hui il y
environ deux mille retraités français
qui sont enregistrés au portugal donc
c'est pas encore un exode massif
mais le gouvernement espère attirer 20
mille retraités en provenance de toute
l'europe dans les prochaines années et
l'immobilier apparaît comme le principal
produit d'appel et dans le reportage le
retraité que l'on voit il m'expliquait
qu'il était en contact avec des
partenaires de bahreïn qui avait pour
projet de racheter un immeuble
complètement délabrée au coeur de
lisbonne de leur habilité et le
transformer en hôtel de luxe
et ces mesures bien sûr procure d'autres
avantages oui car pour tout achat
immobilier de plus de cinq cent mille
euros
eh bien le portugal a décidé d'accorder
un visa de valable 5 ans tous ces
acheteurs un visa mchugh vre les
frontières de l'espace schengen sans mon
processeur du coup ils peuvent circuler
librement en europe donc c'est un moyen
assez simple pour les riches
extracommunautaire de s'acheter un
permis de circulation qui leur permet à
près de mener leurs affaires sur tout le
continent et la question du blanchiment
d'argent se pose alors du blanchiment
qui peut provenir de chine de russie ou
même des balkans est pour l'instant est
bien la commission européenne n'a pas
clarifié la situation laissant les mains
libres à tous ces pays qui veulent
attirer ces riches investisseurs merci
mounir merci voilà c'est fini pour ce
nouveau tour d'europe de la rédaction
rendez vous très vite sur public sénat
et tous les jours sur publicsenat.fr
peu connue du grand public elle pourrait
occuper le poste clé est convoité de
maire de paris